the tragic tale of Adriana Lera was the
saddest ending for any character on the
show Adriana had The Misfortune of Being
targeted by the FBI as a potential way
of getting incriminating information on
Tony Soprano they sent agent Deborah
cicerone undercover to befriend her and
before long Adriana was blabbing her
whole life story to her when Christopher
hit on Deborah and Adriana blamed her
they brought Adriana in and told her
that either she was going to jail or she
was going to become an informant the FBI
wanted her to wear a wire and said she
and Christopher could go into witness
protection when she told Christopher he
in turn told Tony who then made up a
story about Chris being in an accident
and had Sylvio pick Adriana up come on
no no
please Sylvio took her to the woods and
executed her Adriana was killed in the
season 5 episode long-term parking